En este video queremos calcular cuánto es 8 +
7. Les voy a ayudar un poco dibujando lo que
conocemos como bloques de decenas, son útiles
porque, como podemos ver, cada uno de estos
bloques tiene 10 cuadrados: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, o podemos ver que tiene 5 y luego otros
5, lo que suman un total de 10 cuadrados; así
que podemos representar cada uno de estos números
en su propio bloque de decenas. Aquí podemos
completar 8 de esos cuadrados: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, y son 8 + 7, entonces completamos
7 de esos cuadrados: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 y 7.
Así que usando todo esto como una pista, ¿a
cuánto equivale 8 + 7? Pausa en el video y
traten de pensar en esto. Muy bien, ahora
hagamos esto juntos. La razón por la que
son útiles estos bloques de decenas es que
podemos pensar en cuántos de estos círculos
tendríamos que mover de este bloque de decenas
a este otro bloque de decenas para completarlo,
para tener diez justo aquí, y podemos ver que
tenemos dos espacios disponibles. ¿Qué pasaría
si eliminamos dos de estos círculos amarillos
y los pasamos a la izquierda? ¿Qué pasaría,
entonces? Así que vamos a borrar este y
este, y recuerden que no los perdimos,
sólo tenemos que ponerlos en un lugar diferente,
vamos a ponerlos aquí: 1 y 2. Fíjense que todavía
tenemos el mismo número de círculos, todavía
tenemos estos siete círculos amarillos: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, pero los acomodamos un poco
diferente, de modo que dos de ellos completan
el bloque de decenas de la izquierda. Ahora, esto
nos ayuda a pensar en el resultado de esta suma,
porque ahora llenamos todos los cuadrados en
este bloque de decenas de la izquierda. Entonces
sabemos que en este lado izquierdo tenemos 10, y
ahora, ¿cuántos quedan en el lado derecho? Bueno,
podemos ver que en el lado derecho completamos
la mitad de los 10 cuadrados: 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 cuadrados; de modo que 8 + 7 es lo mismo que 10
+ 5, que podemos identificar que es igual a 15,
y obviamente podemos verificar eso contándolos:
tenemos 10 aquí y luego 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.